[موسيقى
] الولايات المتحدة لديها تشيز برجر فيتنام
لديها الرابطة لي المكسيك لديها التورتا
والهند لديها فادا باو ساندويتش
محبوب من قبل الملايين المحبوبين جدًا في الواقع
حاولت ماكدونالدز محاكاتها مع
برجر تيكي الحراري
ولكن لم تنجح لذا دعني أقدم
لك  فادا باف ، هذا هو الفادا
أفضل طريقة لوصفه ، إنه بطاطس مهروسة مقلية عميقًا ،
إنه متبل ولكنه ليس حارًا جدًا ويتم
تقديمه دائمًا ساخنًا وهذا هو
باو باو هو الخبز الذي يجب أن
يفرغ قليلاً عندما تخزه وهناك
الصلصة هناك بعض الجدل حول
المقدار الذي يجب أن يكون موجودًا ولكن هناك شيء
واحد مؤكد أنه يجب أن يكون هناك ، لذلك مع وضع
ذلك في الاعتبار ، سنذهب إلى ثلاثة
أماكن مع ثلاثة أماكن مختلفة
للساندويتش بدءًا من ابن المخترع ،
اسمي ناريندرا  شوك ويف ديا وأنا
أبيعه ولكن على دادا ومومباي ،
بدأ والدي هذا حول قوة في
عام 1966 ، كان فادا باف موجودًا بالفعل ،
لكنني أعتقد أنه كان أول شخص
وضعها بالفعل داخل السلطة  ثم
أعطها لكمة ، أنت بخير ،
هذا ما تريده عندما تصبح كلمة قنبلة
مرتبطة
بالتأكيد بقوة مومباي هي فادا باف ، إنه
طعام مفضل للجميع إنه
خادع تمامًا - ما عارضه هو جيد
كعشاء واحد  واحدة مثل وجبة الإفطار الخاصة بك
بعد ذلك ، سوف نسميها
الأم الوحيدة الشهيرة لا لا لا -
سأقوم بتنظيف شورتي ورأيتني كثيرًا لدرجة
أنه مهما سرق إيماءتي أوليفر
لم يتمكنوا من عدم الثقة في
كل أوتاكو  الآباء لدينا Majesty You
Tube المفضل لدي ، الصحيفة الإنجليزية ،
كانت هذه هي ظاهرة الاستقلالية ،
زبدة الفول السوداني ، زبدة جوز الهند ،
زبدة اللوز
، اذهب وأخبر والدتك أن
والدتك سوف تتعقب
معامل Basava كل ثانية في كل فكرة اسم
صفحة masala الأم  قدم Neela وترًا
آخر إلى ثيتا ، لذا فإن ثيتا
مايكل أود أن أقوم بتعليق التيلجو
، وأخيرًا هذا هو الحديث ، هذا
هو الفأس المسترجع الذي أديره ضخمًا ،
نحن أكبر ما عن جين في
مدينة مومباي  تُعرف السخرية باسم
الشركة التي وصفت أنها كانت
تدور حول عروض فانيا تسخر من ناتشوز جامبو
كين بانير جامبو كينغ ، يوجد ملك جامبو ذو
طابقين ، إنه مختلف
عن رجل الشارع لأننا أكثر
نظافة وهو الابتكار الذي
يحبه الناس حقًا  هي خطيئة
للعبث بالطبق الأصلي ، لكننا
ارتكبنا طريقة الخطيئة هذه مرات عديدة ، لذا
لدينا الآن ثمانية أنواع مختلفة من
الملوك الجامبو ، إنها مزيج رائع
تتلخص هذه القصة بأكملها في شيء واحد
بغض النظر عن الطريقة التي تقدم بها أو
أين  تشتريه ، يجب أن تأكله
لأنه أمر رائع
لك
[موسيقى]